ok I've got whitey getting as bits of
coin and see trans gambled is playing
the other tirage actually i think i
remember i played him before in the
trash or some kind of weird game mp3 now
I don't know so interesting interesting
structure since you really really really
wants to go be five so I'm say anything
that I can do here
yeah I think I can't play quickly i
think this is one of the guys with those
like instant movements and movements and
move and then you lose on time and you
really wonder what exactly happened so
let's just play quickly okay not quite
sure why he wants to go to be seven and
set of f5 okay 93 to c5 as an idea okay
this is the point he wants to wants me
to take and then play on the long
diagonal so probably not ke five might
be might be weak
can go up the window or can go deform
and look at you one of course the I had
a second yeah in just one second the
Queen gets sacrificed it's entirely
incorrect I mean completely incorrect
it's really funny sometimes m so f five
maybe let's be quickly I don't really
want to lose this game on time I mean
this would be heartbreaking after you
get gifted blundered that porn that you
get god gifted the Queen down
so let's see for night h6 not exactly
the ideal place goes there
c7 at some point or book c3 c3
blundering that porn and didn't help but
really didn't help that f5 phone this
isn't dumb I mean yeah there should be
some kind of win but it's not not like
super easy Lucas is seven he can give a
couple of chicks yeah anyway I have to
go okay have seven him Brooks is selling
him I actually hmm could have played
rukka f1 Bishop before maybe check
so I guess check shakier than a five
to those to the a foul I had it very
difficult to win still if possible at
all so let's go here cat ok so he takes
a chance against room
a bit surprised that he wants to do that
and that's the king enter I mean it
probably can allow that but I wouldn't
have done that I would have played just
further for the fortress I mean look on
a two and just stay with the King King
being back maybe he cares a joy anyway
if you look if free checkup before
incensed and stuff it's possible it's
possible that that it is a draw anyway
hmm that's very possible
check time warning
check
check-check
he could have had some very simple roars
I think and I didn't really get what he
was trying there check check check mate
very very strange check check check yeah
okay can certainly take that pawn I
think that it should be should be run so
I think it is really just a draw I mean
if he takes if you let's say puts the
rukon g5 and then shuffled it's a draw I
can sacrifice yeah can sacrifice the
bishop for the pawn and make a fortress
check
so okay that blunders it away was so
something like this I don't really I
don't really see any kind of winning
idea around I was my idea was of course
use the King somehow but it's probably
no use this is the engine line it gives
why the winning position but I'm not I
don't believe much and computer cm as
the computers don't understand
fortresses like this is seven and three
for cone a 3 chat I mean this this is a
draw right what do I get I can never be
some Zeus one
you
and that could be a suit swung my
headset draw that that's really a draw
very strange game but I'm glad them
together get a win in at least of course
it was super stupid to to give away the
eff porn and I didn't understand at all
why he sacrificed the Queen I mean it
wasn't necessary in the least bit I
thought Knight a5 is a move on again
this is just completely lost I mean just
just nothing I just gave away a 5 which
was yeah I simply didn't see that
ebonics like f-5e and like 'if orange
oops it's actually lost this night ok
thanks for watching